i've never heard a coherent argument for
abortion that did not also imply that it
would be perfectly fine to kill other
various human demographics one of the
arguments that cynical people make for
abortion is that it's good because these
kids they'll all be on welfare and
probably grow up and commit crime and
this is a very racist argument because
everyone who makes that argument is
saying that it's good to kill the little
black kids but you wouldn't want to kill
the precious little white kids who grew
up in the suburbs
and the question you have to to ask him
is
which young black man in an inner city
would you be willing to apply that logic
to at the age of 24
and look him in the eye because they're
never called out on the absolute racial
bigotry of it all in new york city more
black babies are killed in the womb than
are born that is horrific and future
generations will look on that barbarity
with great moral appropriation and will
look on the people who advance that with
great moral of program